we're asked to subtract all of this
craziness over here and it looks
daunting but if we really just focus it
actually should be pretty
straightforward to subtract and simplify
this thing because right from the get go
i have four times the fourth root of 81x
to the 5th and from that i want to
subtract 2 times the 4th root of 81 x to
the 5th and so you really can just say
look i have 4 of something and this is
something i'll just circle in yellow i
have 4 of this it could be lemons i have
four of these things and i want to
subtract two of these things these are
the exact same things they're the fourth
root of 81 x to the fifth fourth root of
81 x to the fifth so if i have four of
if i have four lemons and i want to
subtract 2 lemons i'm going to have 2
lemons left over or if i have 4 of this
thing and i take away 2 of this thing
i'm going to have 2 of these things left
over so
these terms right over here simplify to
2 times
the 4th root
of 81
x to the fifth and i got this 2 just by
subtracting the coefficients 4 of
something minus 2 of something is equal
to 2 of that something and then that of
course we still have this
minus the regular principle square root
of x to the third
now i want to try to simplify i want to
try to simplify what's inside of these
under the radical sign so that we can on
this in this example actually take the
fourth root and over here actually take
maybe a principle square root so first
of all let's see if 81 either is a is
something to the fourth power at least
could be factored into something that is
a
something to the fourth power so 81 if
you do prime factorization is 3 times 27
27 is 3 times 9 and 9 is 3 times 3 so 81
is exactly 3 times 3 times 3 times 3. so
81 actually is 3 to the fourth power
which is convenient because we're going
to be taking the fourth root of that and
then x to the fifth we can write as a
product
we can let me write it over here so it
doesn't get messy so i'm going to write
what's under the radical as 3 to the 4th
power times
times x to the fourth power
times x
x to the fourth times x is x to the
fifth power and i'm taking the fourth
root of all of this and taking the
fourth root of all of this that's the
same thing as taking the fourth root of
this
as taking the fourth root of this and
let me just i'm going to want to skip
steps so i'm taking the fourth root i'm
taking the fourth root of all of it
right over there and of course i have a
two out front
and then
x to the third can be written as x
squared times x so it's minus the
principal square root of x squared
times x and i broke it up like this
because this right over here is a
perfect square
now how can we simplify this a little
bit and you're probably getting used to
the pattern this is the same thing as
the fourth root of three to the fourth
times the fourth root of x to the fourth
times the fourth root of x so let's just
skip straight to that so what is
what is the fourth root well i i could
write it let me write it explicitly
although you wouldn't have to
necessarily do this this is the same
thing as the fourth
as the
fourth root of three to the fourth times
the fourth root of x to the fourth times
the fourth root of x
times the fourth root of x and two is
being multiplied times all of that and
then this over here is minus the
principle square root of x squared times
the principal square root of x and so if
we try to simplify it the fourth root of
three to the fourth power
is just three so we get a three there
the fourth root of x to the fourth power
is just going to be x
is just going to be
is just
actually i just remind myself we have to
be careful there it is not just x
because what if x is negative if x is
negative then x to the fourth power is
going to be a positive value and when
you take the fourth remember this is the
fourth principal root you're going to
get the positive version of x or really
you're going to get the absolute value
of x so here you're going to be getting
you're going to be getting the absolute
value of x
and then although well you could make an
argument that x needs to be positive if
this thing is going to be well defined
in the real numbers because then what's
under the radical has to be positive but
let's just go with this for right now
and then we have the fourth root of x
and then over here the the principal
squared of x squared by the same logic
by the same logic is going to be the
absolute value of x and then this is
just the principle square root of x so
let's multiply everything out we have 2
times 3 times the absolute value of x so
2 times 3 is 6
times the absolute value of x
times the principle or the
the principal 4th root of x i should say
minus
minus we've took out the absolute value
of x
times
the principal root of x and we can't do
any more subtracting just because you
have to realize this is a fourth root
this is a regular square root principle
square root if these were the same root
then maybe we could simplify this a
little bit more and so then we are all
done and we have fully simplified it and
if you make the assumption that this is
defined for real numbers so that the
domain over here this what has to be
under these radicals has to be positive
actually in every one of these cases and
if there need to be positive we're not
going to be dealing with imaginary
numbers all of these need to be positive
their domains our x has to be greater
than or equal to zero then you could
assume that the absolute value of x is
the same as x but i'll just stick it
right here if you restrict the domain
you could get rid of the absolute value
signs